oh goody Time magazine released its 2017
Person of the Year finalist on The Today
Show a few on their list
well illegal alien dreamers demanding
citizenship the me to most movement I'm
not a person by the way that hashtag me
too and the kneeler in chief quarterback
Colin Kaepernick and speaking of cap the
ACLU honored him last night with their
courageous advocate award he offered
this trenchant wisdom we all have an
obligation no matter the risk and
regardless of reward to stand up for our
fellow men and women who been oppressed
who men and women who are being
oppressed with the understanding that
human rights cannot be compromised wait
and kneeling during the anthem achieves
any of that oh okay well suggesting
suggestion to the ACLU and Time magazine
I know of some really courageous
advocates who never taken me maybe when
they're proposing to their girlfriend or
boyfriend and since this year marks
there are 240 second birthday they are
the ideal person of the year try the
Marines Semper Fi baby it seems all of
our institutions are capitulating though
doesn't it to this toxic culture and
perhaps even the military why am I
saying that well we'll find out in a
moment joining us without our to
veterans with different perspectives of
the issue Fox News contributor Pete
hexif and in Atlanta Democratic
strategist strategist I'm talking like
George W Bush Robin Bureau Robin let's
start with you great to see you so I
goofed a little bit on time Person of
the Year I think this is long past its
usefulness at this point remember a few
years ago it was you that was that was
like the winner you think the internet
there's nothing a person anymore it's
just like a hashtag or like a chair it's
like Clint Eastwood's chair at the
debate should have been the person of
the year so on this question of
Kaepernick though Dean do you really buy
into that as a as a real game changer
changer for this year well you know I
mean if you look at the list there's a
lot of people on there that just this is
basically some pop culture things but I
do have to say that with Kaepernick I do
appreciate that he's standing for his
convictions and he
buddy that does that I do respect and
appreciate I've had to do that I've
actually had to speak out against some
party some people within the Democratic
Party myself and I had to stand for some
convictions that could have caused me
some repercussions and it was
uncomfortable but you know you do what
you feel you have to do morally and at
the end of the day he did that I respect
his reasons he even had a Special Forces
veteran consult with him on how to
respectfully protest which was to take a
deal which in the in the military as you
as my fellow knows that is a sign that
you are injured so it may have been the
one Green Beret that got it wrong okay
anyone knows who's who or in the uniform
to stand for the national anthem he
succeeded in getting fired not getting
rehired muddying his cause tanking NFL
ratings and that maybe extorting the NFL
for ninety million dollars was an upside
for him he wants to be playing
interceptions
yeah and ultimately was not he's we
don't really know what his cause was
generally speaking but when you look at
when you look at this entire list i'm
kim jong un's on list
he'll probably you should get it this
year because you'll probably be dead
next year the only person who should
make it is Trump Trump Trump over in the
media upside down has turned politics
upside down for that have they had a
cover with not a Trump they're obsessed
with well good well you know what
manatee or you should be the man of the
note but it's the person of the year
Laurel how its person if he ran against
political correctness yeah that's part
of the reason he got elected so let's
remember that even even the name of the
the the award itself is the reason why
he's so sick Robert I have to ask you a
question about this an other issue that
came up today we were gonna get into it
but I do think it's pretty interesting
now if you smoke pot it doesn't
disqualify you from military service and
I know a lot of the kids they've tried
pot and I'm not in favor of it but I
like know a lot of people have they
recruit about 80,000 people a year I
believe into the all the branches of the
Armed Forces
do you think this is a good thing that
it's like a slippery slope it's lowering
the standards or ain't no big deal as
long as you're not token up now well as
a veteran Ranger I
a bunch of my ranger buddies and most
all of them agreed I did a poll on our
little Facebook group of about 4,000
people and by and large overwhelmingly
they said that as long as you didn't has
positive when you're at MEPs that they
didn't see it as a reason to be serviced
disqualifying because a lot of kids do
this especially if you've got to
consider the states that this is
legalized in and a lot of these guys
want to join the military to change
their lives and give back to society I
can respect that
so you know I understand the need for
more waivers there are so many high
school students who don't qualify by
body mass index standards all of that oh
you don't think that way and we're
trying to build we're trying to build up
our military they're building up the
wrong way they're building up the width
instead of the rank that's the problem
we have we have a major obesity epidemic
Michelle Obama recognized that and
unfortunately it's perfect it's really
affecting recruiting is much the amount
of guys food toss much smaller than it
used to be yeah we do live in a
different culture though where marijuana
is being legalized totally against a
totally against I get that if you're
some young kid who's in a state where
tantalized and you did it once or twice
and you can't go to the military problem
is prior performance is indicative of
your future and so if you if you're a
pothead and you want to go to the
military why is the army lowering its
standard and saying we want you in
that's a list of the transgenderism in
the military the mat now Trump kicked it
over to Madison Madison kind of in the
middle of the of the bureaucracy of DoD
I think Trump wants to do the right
thing as with so many things what will
the bureaucracy try to change what are
you afraid of the social engineering has
been ingrained political practice has
been ingrained into what our military
does so many great people that want to
do good things but their incentives for
their next promotion it gets more
political as you get higher to the time
now it says means that you know you go
along to get along
I hope this administration will actually
change that trend it's like hot potato
don't want driving a quick take on the
transgender issue what will ultimately
happen with mattis oh that sounds that's
a we've been covering that for so long
and that's actually been the most
controversial thing I've ever talked
about on this network I've been on this
probably 200 times I got more flak from
so you don't okay okay okay you're cool
just tell us what you think is gonna
happen right in time my frie okay out of
time got it it's gonna we're going to
vet the ones that are currently in to
see if they're able to serve and I do
believe they may put a ban on maybe this
surgical procedure itself at least we
don't pay for surgical procedures maybe
maybe the VA hasn't started the business
oh we're on our way
yeah well I appreciate both of you thank
you both of us Donald Trump a man of the
ER Donald Trump